he told us
to um do both of you well he told me
that the thing that would help it was
drinking
his
like four times a week
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are game to try anything to have a baby
it's a beautiful thing the couple's
fertility journey continues to be
documented on the latest episode of
hulu's the kardashians and because the
egg retrieval process hasn't been going
well they commit to doing a cleanse our
new thing that we're going to be trying
is a panchakarma cleanse which is
ayurvedic it's like 3000 years old
which will
get all of the toxins that are like deep
within our tissue
out of our bodies to have better quality
eggs and we're on day two of our cleanse
i just want to hear all like the
lines that's why i can't exercise yeah
why i'm on restriction
all the way around the couple turns to
an expert for help that's when travis
gives more details about those
restrictions she's mad at me a little
bit because no i love her i love her no
i miss caffeine i miss having sex and i
miss exercising i understand that's all
then court reveals the shocking advice
her fertility doctor told her to
increase her chances of getting pregnant
he told me that the thing that would
help it was drinking
his
like four times a week
okay
i love this doctor we're just you know
living our best lives and
yeah of course court already has three
kids of her own with ex scott disick
mason penelope and rayne and travis he
shares three kids with ex-wife shana
moakler atiana landon and alabama you
know my main concern is always you know
my children are my first priority and
you know that's one thing that you know
travis and i you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness back in february a
source told et that the two want to have
a child together and the idea of adding
to their bunch is very important and
exciting to them i'm super grateful that
travis is doing this with me i don't
think i can do it on my own i just feel
like it's something like we have to do
together we're making a baby together
it's like
we have to be on the same page in the
meantime court and trav are fresh off
from celebrating their italian wedding
a source tells e.t the newlyweds
couldn't be happier and their italy
wedding is everything they ever wanted
their friends and family are all so
thrilled for them and can see how in
love they are even when they're doing a
cleanse that restricts them from their
favorite things their love is still on
full display me and travis are doing the
wildest cleanse right now we started
what what no sex no caffeine no working
out sex have to do with it so we were
like what about oral sex what about
hands what about feet what about feet
anything
baby
[Music]
you